fear The Walking Dead is AMC's prequel
to The Walking Dead but it's a totally
different beast in the original fear
takes place in a world that's much more
similar to ours than the
post-apocalyptic cell it's really easy
to see yourself in the shoes of Travis
Madison Alicia
Tobias Nick I mean not so much the
heroin-addicted Nick but Tobias
definitely if you're on the internet
right now you probably relate most to
Tobias you say it's not connected it is
reports in five states it's spread if
you need to spend less time online that
guy knows what he's talking about
basically what would happen in society
collapsed today
how would you learn about it what would
you do where would you go
and would you survive we'll find out in
this hashtag news as we explained how
the zombie apocalypse could really
happen all right
I'm drew Coolidge and this is hashtag
news let's really dig into the guts of
fear of The Walking Dead warning
spoilers are ahead we've seen zombie
apocalypses taken seriously in countless
movies and of course our own history has
examples of how humanity will react in
crisis situations
in fear the walking dead the zombies are
real but they haven't taken over yet
people are still going about their daily
lives and news about illness and
creatures are still just kind of
background noise one of our first public
zombie sightings in the show is from a
grainy cell phone footage which let's be
real is exactly how it's gonna happen
remember the bath salts incident in
Florida in 2012 a lot of people thought
that was a zombie when actually was just
a crazed man on drugs people would talk
around the water cooler some reddit
thread would pop up in WTF with proof
jokes talking airborne toxins poison
water viruses this is why we must stay
on the rumors you hear might very well
be true so don't just wait for the
government to tell you something like
Madison hey if there's a problem we're
gonna know about it
the authorities would tell us once
everybody knows it's too late but it
wouldn't go away there would be more and
more reports of strange attacks
happening around the world kids would be
absent from school
five would you miss a few stops finally
major news outlets would start reporting
it and once it went from rumor to
official [ __ ] gets real let's take a
second here and talk about how fast
something like this can spread a paper
presented to the American Physical
Society stated that in a byte based
zombie outbreak a heavily populated
place like Los Angeles could fall in
just 24 hours maybe it's time to buy a
secluded cabin somewhere people will
start to go missing or go zombie really
fast first responders like police and
medical personnel will be some of the
first attacked in the line of duty and
millions of boyfriend's around the world
will finally have a reason why they're
not answering their texts sorry babe I'm
a zombie you try to go find your loved
ones and friends but roads would become
impossible listen where's my son I don't
know it was chaotic you need to call the
police I'm sorry he's gone people
without their medication would be in a
world of hurt and forced to either
stockpile or raid pharmacies the looters
hit pharmacies first I mean look at all
of fun Nick is having he's going through
withdrawals while the world is
collapsing outside the apocalypse as an
addict is tough really anything as an
addict is tough but the apocalypse
every basic service we know would cease
or be severely limited trash would pile
up power would go out communications
will fail because no one's there to
manage the servers the electrical grid
will collapse for the same reason it's
all gonna go to hell and if that's what
they don't get when when civilization
ends it ends fast Tobias you are the
harbinger of the Apocalypse we'd lose
communication services the internet is
way more fragile than you might think
more than 99% of global web traffic is
dependent on deep sieve networks of
fiber-optic cables that kind of blanket
the ocean floor like a nervous system if
these cables are disrupted and no one's
around to fix it it's only a matter of
time before those system breaks down and
stays down Twitter Google Facebook all
gone
this really is the apocalypse local
police are doing their best but they're
getting stretched thin I need you to
call 911 when law-and-order is gone some
people try to escape and do the right
thing while other people just take
advantage of the broken system to steal
whatever they can that's when the panic
starts
except this time it isn't just panic
it's violence and panic looting and
attacking each other it's like Black
Friday but forever with zombies mixed in
now the zombie threat is established the
military is obviously going to take
action
all military personnel would be called
for duty to attempt to restore law and
order while keeping the disease at bay
in that time I could see martial law
being declared infected zones being
locked down our government has published
a real counter zombie plan that's true
it's called complan 8888 11 and it was
quote not designed as a joke so that's
good it's very technical and boring
which is how you know it's real in it we
learned the president would be whisked
away to a fortified bunker most likely
off at Air Force Base in Omaha Nebraska
that's where President Bush was taken
during 9/11 is basically the country's
crisis White House if you look at most
disaster responses like any hurricane
here in the US government's have
provided shelter food and water to those
in need this could lead to protected
safe zones being built and overseen by
the government these camps will be used
to protect the living but most likely
you'll have to get screened in order to
qualify if you're infected well then you
may be left for dead well what if you
look at most disaster responses
governments have provided shelter food
and water to those in need
but normally this is in the aftermath
not during a global crisis that is
trying to eat you now not all is lost we
have some very smart scientists at the
CDC unless they go a little crazy this
is our extinction event and as long as
it's not some sort of hyper mutating
virus we can hopefully get some kind of
cure going
now unfortunately con plan 8888 11 is
not that great first of all nukes are
suggested as an option now we know to
get rid of zombies you got to kill their
brain nukes would kill their brain their
bodies the forest around it the entire
city most of the country can we hold
back at some nukes for just a second a
couple of head shots is all we need
a couple million headshots even worse
the plan specifically states that
military bases couldn't hold more than
30 days of food and water that's less
than a month of zombie fighting before
we're all dead 28 days later will happen
28 days later the takeaway here is that
if the military wants to fight a zombie
horde they're gonna have to adapt get
away run get out of town provided you
come up with that idea before everyone
else has that idea just - some supplies
and head for the hills no suburbs no
urban centers just wilderness get away
from the city we need to get away from
people's a desert yeah it'll be okay
there will be safe don't forget
sunscreen guys hopefully this is where
all of your extensive wilderness
training will kick in what's that you
don't have any Oh me neither
oh there is more hope for our world
rather than the fear of the walking dead
world because we're more informed in
these characters zombies and zombie
culture doesn't exist in the Walking
Dead universe so we do have that leg up
on this universe since we think about
and see zombies all the time if I see
some lumbering guy eating a person I'm
gonna say hey that's a zombie and
everyone's gonna go oh yeah we know
exactly what that is shoot him in the
head don't get bitten he got run over
and stood back up he must be a zombie we
know exactly what that is
we're smart I'm excited about fear The
Walking Dead we get to witness
everyone's first zombie kill
special moment are you scared now you
should be you should fear the walking
dead I have hopes a.m. so you can pull
it off what do you guys think who do you
think will live who will die in the new
show what would you do if this happened
for real let me know in the comments and
subscribe as we follow along with AMC's
fear The Walking Dead and while the
zombie apocalypse isn't real natural
disasters are it's a good idea to
prepare for them so give North quake
King watch my video about earthquakes
get another earthquake kit etc me I try
to have a contingency plan for every
real and make-believe disaster Ted quiz
me tornado what where no I'm never burn
not real oh I still drank all of our
emergency water